so how would you rate the performance of
the um
department of health the uh secretary of
state outstanding
good requires improvement or inadequate
and why
um i think that there were some
brilliant
like in much of the government system
there was many brilliant people
at relatively junior and middle levels
who were terribly let down by
senior leadership i think that
i think that the secretary of state for
health should have been fired
for at least 15 20 things including
lying to everybody
in multiple occasions in meeting after
meeting in the in the cabinet room and
publicly
rosie oh dear um in that case
do you think people should be worried
about facing corporate manslaughter
charges
i don't know about that because i don't
really know what the kind of laws are
and
the rules are but i think i think that
um i think that there is no
doubt that many senior people
were
just terrible as i said in my opening
statement i think there's no doubt at
all that many senior people
performed far far disastrously below
the standards which the country has a
right to expect
i think that the secretary of state for
health is
certainly one of those people i said
repeatedly to the prime minister that he
should be fired
so did the cabinet secretary so did many
other senior people
i just wanted to pick up something that
you said mr cummings i think i heard you
correctly in accusing the health
secretary of having lied
um did i hear that correctly yes um
can you that's obviously a serious
charge can you provide the committee
with the
the evidence behind that assertion
yes i mean um in
there there are numerous examples i mean
in the summer he said that everyone who
needed treatment
who got the treatment that they required
he knew that that was a lie
because he'd been briefed by the chief
scientific advisor and the chief medical
officer himself about the first peak
and we were told explicitly people did
not get the treatment that they deserved
many people were left to die in horrific
circumstances is that the basis of your
assertion are there
other pieces is that the basis of your
assertion or are there other
pieces of evidence that you base that
that charge on
yes i mean in in in mid april um
the uh so at the the just before the
prime minister and i were diagnosed with
having covered ourselves
the secretary of state for health told
us in the cabinet room
everything is fine on ppe we've got it
all covered
et cetera et cetera when i came back
almost the first meeting i had
in the cabinet room was about the
disaster over
over ppe and how we were actually
completely sure that hospitals all over
the country were
running out secretary of state said in
that meeting
this is the fault of simon stevens it's
the fault of the chancellor of the
exchequer
it's not my fault they've blocked
approvals on all sorts of things
i said to the cabinet secretary please
investigate this and find out if it's
true
the government secretary came back to me
and said it's completely untrue
i have lost confidence in the secretary
of state's honesty
in these meetings the cabinet secretary
said the cabinet secretary said that to
me and the government secretary said
that to
to to the prime minister did you make a
note of that at the time
yes could you supply that to the
committee
yes and for to
to corroborate the accusation that
you've made against the health secretary
you've given orally some um
what is in your mind when you make that
charge uh i'd be grateful if you'd write
to the company
to set it up so that we can consider it
obviously that's a very serious thing to
say